today on the matt walsh show netflix has
officially released the
cuties movie about twerking 11 year olds
many defenders of the film in the media
said that the outrage against the film
was off base and that its
detractors were taking things out of
context well
now the full movie is publicly available
and it turns out it's even worse
than we thought also five headlines
including another shocking scandal that
is sure to bring down donald trump at
least that's what
they tell me on cnn uh but what's what's
the truth behind that we'll get into it
and in our daily cancellation i am sad
to report
that i must cancel my wife
yet again um hate to do it but i i think
this is our seventh cancellation
all of that on the way but first you
know and this will become even more
apparent in the topic we're about to
jump into here but
it's really hard these days to find
companies that support
your values so you know we have two
challenges as consumers
find companies that have great products
and services and then two
find companies that check off that box
but also share our values
well i'm happy to report that charity
mobile checks both boxes which is why
i'm a charity mobile customer you should
be too charity mobile is the pro-life
phone company
what does that mean well it means five
percent off your monthly plan price goes
to pro-life
pro-family charities of your choice uh
new activations and eligible accounts
get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping so there
are a lot of perks as well
as you know supporting this cause that's
so important there's no contracts no
termination fees
and no risk with a 30-day guarantee the
other great thing
you've got live customer service based
in the usa and you also have the ability
to block
use of cellular data picture messages
text messages
on any and all or all of your accounts
all of the lines on your account so you
get that additional security as well
listen you can help build a culture of
life in america
while supporting a pro-life company um
this is the ultimate sort of win-win you
get something you need
good service awesome product um a
company that's great to do business with
and at the same time you're supporting
the pro-life cause which is the most
central the most foundational
cause of all call charity mobile at
1-877-474-3662 or chat with us
online at charitymobile.com
okay here's a company that does not
share our values
several weeks ago netflix began
promoting a new film from french
director
maimuna dankori probably mispronouncing
that but
the movie's called cuties and the poster
featuring scantily-clad children posing
suggestively caused
well-deserved outrage when it first
appeared the sundance film festival
which honored the film with a directing
award
provided a synopsis that didn't do much
to quell the anger either according to
sundance
cuties tells the story of an 11 year old
girl named amy who
quote through an ignited awareness of
her burgeoning femininity
propels the group to enthusiastically
embrace
and increasingly sensual dance routine
uh sparking the girls hope to torque
their way to stardom
at a local dance contest it's perhaps
perhaps worth mentioning here that
sundance was co-founded by a man
who is now in prison for child sexual
abuse i don't know i just wanted to
throw that in there the film's official
description from netflix was only
slightly less grotesque sounding
and they they said amy 11 becomes
fascinated with a twerking dance crew
hoping to join them
she starts to explore her femininity
defying her family's traditions
now after the backlash netflix
apologized not for the film itself but
simply for the inappropriate artwork
they said the streaming service also
changed the synopsis getting rid of any
mention of twerking
and instead calling it a free-spirited
dance group
netflix did not bother to explain why
they used that
quote-unquote inappropriate artwork in
the first place to promote
the film you know if it doesn't actually
reflect the content
and if they're not trying to attract an
audience of pedophiles who wish to see
pubescent girls gyrate on stage then
what was the thought process behind the
way it was originally marketed
we were never told the website bustle
said that
the poster was simply botched now i can
understand
botching a poster with a typo or some
other error due to carelessness but
how do you botch something by
accidentally turning it into softcore
child porn that's my question
many other media outlets rushed to the
defense of the twerking children movie
an article by anna menta on the decider
scolded the film's detractors
baselessly linking the criticism to the
q anon conspiracy theory
and said that we all owe the director an
apology
richard broder at the new yorker called
the movie extraordinary
and blasted the scurrilous campaign
launched by right wingers to criticize
the movie
the rolling stones david fear gave
cuties a positive review saying that the
outrage is all the product of a
major misleading marketing mistake the
independent
joined the chorus of defenders declaring
uh quote cuties on netflix is too moving
a film to be marred by one
bad taste poster many outlets such as
npr claim that the film
actually criticizes and exposes the
sexualization of children
actress tessa thompson said that she was
gutted by the
quote beautiful film and that the quote
current discourse
misses the fact that the movie comments
on the hypersexualization of
pre-adolescent girls
overall the outrage certainly did not
deter the media from
hailing cuties as an artistic triumph as
you could tell
in fact as we speak it sits at 90 fresh
on review aggregator site rotten
tomatoes with critics saying other
things like
it's refreshingly frank about class
religion and burgeoning sexuality
in ways that mainstream american movies
would never dare and also quote
cuties certainly deserves to be seen
for a while the film's valiant defenders
in the media in hollywood
had the advantage of being the only
people to have actually seen it
the rest of us could but make
assumptions based on the it would seem
rather significant fact
that it's a movie about 11 year olds
twerking which netflix had decided to
market with a picture of said 11 year
olds
barely clothed and striking sexual poses
but
you can't judge a movie by its child
porn cover we were told
and then yesterday the film was finally
released it turns out
unsurprisingly you can as
fuller clips from the film now circulate
online i won't play any of them here
because honestly i'd worry about the fbi
breaking down my door if i did
it's clear that those of us who
criticized the movie actually
understated our case it is if anything
way
worse than we assumed and feared
some examples one scene features the 11
year old girls gyrating and slapping
each other on the butt
as the camera zooms in for close-ups
another shows amy in her underwear
furiously thrusting her body as she lays
on the floor
again camera gives close-ups uh in
another the girls dance provocatively
for two grown men
one of whom looks on with obvious and
creepy satisfaction
and still another amy pulls down her
pants uh and takes a picture of her
crotch and posts it online
and the pen in the penultimate scene
which was featured on the original
poster before netflix changed it
that scene is significantly more
disturbing than the already disturbing
image led on
the scene drags on for several minutes
the dancing is
highly highly sexualized and the camera
as always
zooms in for crotch shots and other
close-ups
this is not a commentary on child sexual
exploitation
it is child exploitation clear as day
in all its sadism and remember the
characters
and the actors who play them are 11
years old
with these horrific scenes now publicly
available it seems almost
pointless to engage with the plainly
absurd notion
that the filmmakers had 11 year old
children writhe around and gyrate on
stage
while barely clothed as some kind of
protest against the sexualization of
children
it would be like a slasher film
featuring several scenes of various
screaming victims being disemboweled
claiming in its defense that it only
meant to comment
on the problem of graphic violence in
film indeed
that actually is the defense often
offered for slasher fix
flicks and and it's as weak in that case
as it is here the guy who made
texas chainsaw massacre may have told
himself that he had higher intentions
but the fact remains
that most people who watch texas
chainsaw massacre just want to see
well a chainsaw massacre i suppose when
it comes down to it
no filmmaker wants to come out and admit
that they produced gratuitous garbage
for a lowest common denominator audience
but many filmmakers do produce that sort
of material for that sort of audience
whether they admit it or not and cuties
belongs
on that ghastly heap for sure hopefully
buried underneath it somewhere
deep where it cannot be seen despite the
pretensions of anamenta
at the decider and many others in media
the normalization of pedophilia
is not a right-wing fairy tale or a q
anon conspiracy theory
it is real it is happening
here's exhibit a or you know not even
exhibit a i mean
this is a long line of exhibits it's
it's right in front of us
for us to see you know um
yes do you have the normalization of
pedophilia in a culture
where a movie like this not just exists
okay it's not just this that some some
pervert some creep made this movie and
it's
it's out there in the hinterland
somewhere uh out on the fringes and no
one's seen it
this is being uh
promoted and and supplied to us to the
to the american audience
by a billion dollar streaming platform
and
major media publications have come out
in its defense
strenuously uh to defend it
you wouldn't have that in a culture that
didn't normalize
pedophilia and child sexual exploitation
i mean this is this is a country where
children are sent to the library to be
read stories by drag queens
uh this is a country where uh you know
planned parenthood
goes into middle schools and high
schools to hand out birth control
this is a country where we've got you
know quote unquote sex ed in elementary
schools
telling kids about masturbation and
other things
so yes this is a a real
plan uh among the powers that be in our
culture to sexualize
children there is no doubt about it
and this right here from netflix i mean
if this is not
reason if this if this does not convince
us all to cancel our netflix
subscriptions if we still have them
then um then i don't know what will
there have to be real penalties for
something like this
we can't just complain about it and say
how horrible this is and then go about
our married
merry way while still paying netflix our
subscription fee we cannot do that
uh if there was ever a reason for a
boycott
this is it right here so let's all do
that today let's cancel our netflix
subscriptions
that's that's the least we can do that's
step one let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
you know if we want to be responsible
and smart then we need to protect
our online data there's just no reason
to be going we all spend so much time
online
probably more time than we want to admit
i know that's the case for me
uh but if you're not protecting yourself
then it just
uh there's there's there's no excuse for
that whatsoever
that's why you need expressvpn did you
know that your internet service provider
like comcast of verizon knows every
single website you visit
and what's worse is they can sell this
information to add companies and tech
giants who will use your data to target
you
and look this is this is your data
there's no reason why you have to expose
yourself to that expressvpn puts a stop
to this it creates a secure encrypted
tunnel
between your device and the internet so
that your online activity can't be seen
by anyone
i use expressvpn on all my devices it
works on everything phones laptops
routers so everyone who shares your
wi-fi can still be protected even if
they don't have expressvpn the best part
is
using expressvpn is as easy as you know
closing the bathroom door
to give yourself privacy you just fire
up the app click one button
and you're protected it really is that
simple expressvpn is the world's
number one rated vpn by cnet uh wired
the verge
countless others they're all in uh
there's a consensus that expressvpn is
the way to go so if you're like me and
you believe your online activity is your
business
secure yourself by visiting
expressvpn.com
walsh today use my exclusive link that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
walsh and you can get an extra three
months for free that's expressvpn
walsh okay
let me pull up our news headlines if i
can find them here they are
okay of course you know the big news i'm
told supposedly is president donald
trump
telling bob woodward in march that he
wants to play down the coronavirus
um this is all going to appear in
woodward's forthcoming book
rage about the trump administration i
wonder if it's going to have a positive
or negative spin i don't know it's hard
to tell you can never tell who knows
impossible to predict um this
conversation between charlotte woodward
is on tape
you probably heard the tape by now but
if not here it is again
it goes through air bob that's always
tougher than the touch you know the
touch you don't have to touch things
right but the
air you just breathe the air and that's
how it's uh
passed and so that's a very tricky one
that's a very delicate one
uh it's also more deadly than your you
know
your even your strenuous flus you know
people don't realize we lose twenty five
thousand thirty thousand people a year
here who would ever think that right
i know that's pretty amazing and then i
say well is that
the same thing for this is more deadly
this is
five per you know this is five percent
versus
one percent and less than one percent
you know so
this is deadly stuff so what is going on
give me an
a moment of talking to somebody going
through this
with faushi or somebody who kind of
it caused a pivot in your mind because
it's clear just from
what's in on the public record that you
went through
a pivot on this to oh my god the gravity
is uh almost inexplicable and
unexplainable well i think bob really
to be honest with you sir i want you to
i wanted to
uh i wanted to always play it down i
still like playing it down yes because i
don't want to create a panic
okay there you go and uh he also said
trump said at other times early in
february that the virus is deadly stuff
and worse than the flu and the claim
from trump's critics is that these
private statements contradict what he
said publicly
and show that he lied to the public
there's a lot more in these interviews
he did
18 interviews with woodward 18. many of
them
apparently recorded 18 interviews
here's what i'll say about this first of
all he did say in those comments just
played
that he was he was he was playing it
down quote unquote in order to prevent
the public from panicking
now i don't think preventing a panic is
a good reason for a public official to
lie
if you're going to accept that excuse
from the government for lying
then you can't ever criticize the
government for lying because that's
always
the excuse for lying from the government
but
on the other hand i don't think that
trump actually was lying necessarily i
think that
what you heard there was more a
reflection of trump's limited vocabulary
than anything else
he said play it down but in the context
it seemed like he really meant to say
something like
allay fears or something like that that
probably would have
caught his meaning a little bit uh
better i think
and besides his public comments were
also
all over the place so if his private
comments were all over the place and his
public comments were all over the place
there are a lot of criticisms you can
make towards him about that but i don't
think you can accuse him of deception or
conspiracy or a cover-up or something
like that
it sounds like the guy was sort of
flailing which is certainly the
impression he gave publicly
as well as privately um so i think all
in all this is not a huge ski it's not
the huge scandal the left wants it to be
it doesn't reflect well on trump either
but it's not a breathtaking scandal
which is of course what they what they
are hoping for now that
said my real issue here is that trump
decided to do
18 recorded interviews
with a guy who was writing an expose
about him which
would come out before the election um
that is
inexcusably stupid and it shows
what i've always said which is that
trump is not media savvy at all he gets
credit for
he's a master at media manipulation no
he
just does and says stuff randomly
and the media is so incompetent that it
often works out in trump's favor
but a media savvy president would not do
recorded interviews
18 times with a guy who is clearly
against you
and wants to write a hit piece on you if
trump actually thought there was
any chance that bob woodward would write
a positive book about him
then that's the dumbest thing of all um
there is just no scenario where that
works in your favor
the best you can hope for i know that
the people defending trump are saying us
isn't going to hurt him okay well
that's the best you can hope for you sit
down for 18 recorded interviews with bob
woodward
best possible outcome is that it's it's
neutral it doesn't hurt you
in which case it was a waste of time
worst outcome is that it does hurt you
there is no universe at all in which it
helps you
in which prattling to bob woodward 18
times
uh with recordings somehow works in your
favor it just
it just it's not going to so there's no
reason to do it
uh why did trump do it then well because
trump is incapable of saying no to
someone
who wants to give him attention uh you
know it's it really is that simple and
that's
one of his great weaknesses uh
i think okay number two from the daily
wire it says attorney general william
barr announced wednesday that operation
legend a department of justice program
designed to supplement major city to
police departments with federal agents
and resources amid an unprecedented
national crime wave
has cut the chicago murder rate roughly
in half
since launch and has reversed a surge of
violence that was leaving dozens killed
it says looking for the actual numbers
here about
chicago the results of those actions
speak for themselves over the past five
weeks of operation legend in chicago
murders dropped by 50
over the previous five weeks august
ultimately saw a 45
decrease in murders compared to july and
a 35
decrease compared to june okay
so if i'm interpreting the data here
correctly it would seem that the
takeaway
is that enforcing the law
helps reduce crime yes when
when you allow criminals to commit crime
without consequence you get more crime
when you impose a consequence you get
less crime there would seem to be a
cause and effect
relationship here possibly and this is
why i've been saying for a long time
that that all of this talk about
criminal justice reform
is focused on reforming in exactly the
wrong way
there is not a crisis in our country of
innocent people being sent to jail
or criminals being given sentences that
are too harsh
that's not now that kind of thing does
happen
on occasion but that's not the systemic
issue the systemic issue is that
violent dangerous people are filtered
quickly through the system
and then sent back out onto the streets
that's the systemic problem the systemic
issue is that many people
um many of the people out in the street
committing crime
are known to the system to be criminals
and to be dangerous
and yet they're allowed to remain free
great example of this okay
just from this week as well in new york
a guy named daniel biggs
you can see the video here he rode his
bike passed a six-year-old woman
punched her in the head and knocked her
to the ground
and and just kept on riding now
fortunately a bunch of firefighters saw
this happen and were able to chase him
down and apprehend him which is good
but biggs is 53 years old apparently
has 18 prior arrests for robbery assault
and other crimes
now he's out randomly assaulting women
who are just walking down the street
this is a man with nothing to offer a
society
um just violence and crime that's all
he's got to offer
it's all he's got to give uh the re
there is just no reason
to have him out on the street there's no
reforming
somebody like this someone who's been a
scumbag their entire life
and now at the age of 53 is still out
randomly assaulting people just for fun
there's no reforming there's no real
hope
that one day this will be a productive
member of society
this is someone who you throw into a
cage and you keep them there
forever okay you say to that person
you're done you've had your chance
you've had many chances
you clearly don't want to behave like a
human being you're not interested in
that
so this is what you get we're going to
throw you in a cage
but what happened to biggs though well
he was charged a few days later
and released on bail they released him
18 arrests he's doing that they release
him out on bail what do you think
is biggs going to show up diligently for
his court appearance
is he going to wear a nice suit come to
the court on the day that's
assigned and you know face his the
consequences like a man
no of course not so
this is the way it works guys like this
filter through the system
and they end up back on the street
commit more crimes the system is way way
way too lenient
not too harsh and that's where the
reform should be focused so it's good
that um
at least on the federal level we're
starting to see some of that okay a man
named safwan chowdhury
posted video yesterday that he says
shows him and his family being kicked
off a west jet flight
in fact the whole flight was was
canceled as a matter of fact because his
19 month old child
was not wearing a mask you can't see or
hear much in the video but i'll play it
for you anyway here it is
this is
[Music]
everyone
your
[Music]
now westjet in defense of itself says
that um
no the problem was not the 19 month old
it was the
uh three-year-old daughter was not
wearing a mask so they canceled the
flight because of that chowdhury
disputes that claim and so there's a he
said he said thing going on
uh here here's here's how it shakes out
as far as i can tell
number one expecting a baby a 19 month
old to wear a mask
is madness and dangerous babies can
suffocate very easily
um you don't you don't put any kind of
fabric
or anything around the face of a baby
period any business that requires that
should be sued
any parent who complies with that is
stupid and gutless beyond words
absolutely you don't put a mask on a
baby you lunatics
but what if it was just the
three-year-old that was the issue well
guess what still stupid
just as stupid many three-year-olds
aren't gonna
cooperate with having a mask on and
shouldn't be required to
and it doesn't seem very healthy to me
to have a three-year-old who's panicking
because they don't understand why they
have to have the sting on their face
restricting their breathing
and now they're you know they're trying
to breathe hard they're panicking
they're screaming they got the mask on
no i have a three-year-old uh myself
he's not gonna wear a mask for any long
period of time
he'll put one on for like 45 seconds
mainly just because he sees everyone
else doing it
but then it's going to come off and i'm
not going to force him to wear it i've
said i've said many times that as far as
i'm concerned if a business wants me to
wear a mask i will respect their
property
rights and comply with that even though
i don't like it
but no you're not going to force me to
put a mask on my three-year-old it's
just not going to happen
but here's the thing that really uh gets
to me about this
going back to that video okay you heard
the child crying
obviously scared confused so
when you think about that requiring
little kids to put masks on
or you know the latest now they're gonna
be canceling trick or treat
uh in i think chicago said they're
probably gonna cancel it
even though you're outside the kids are
already wearing masks and costumes so
there's no reason to do it but they're
gonna do it anyway
um or any of the other millions of
examples of the way the ways that kids
have been affected by this
what gets me is that none of this is
about protecting the kids themselves
okay this is not some sort of misguided
but well-meaning attempt to protect
children
i personally have a lot of sympathy for
misguided but well-meaning attempts to
protect children
i sympathize with that because i get it
you know i
i understand as a father i understand
how sometimes you could go a little
overboard in your zealousness to protect
children um
i can certainly be guilty of that
sometimes i mean you should see the way
that i cut up food for my three-year-old
it's as if he's an infant cut it up with
these little tiny like microscopic bits
because i'm terrified it'll choke you
know it's it's way overboard
my wife makes fun of me but uh i i can't
help it
it's my greatest fear as a kid choking
so i go way overboard sometimes too to
protect
them in certain areas but that's not
what this is about with the coronavirus
no this is about selfish and scared
adults trying to protect
themselves from the kids
insisting that a baby wear a mask and
i'm counting a three-year-old as a baby
in this in this context
insisting that a baby wear a mask no
matter how scared and confused and
terrified he is
or how unhealthy it is for him in order
so that you
can be protected from him is the height
of cowardice and selfishness
i mean even even leaving aside the fact
that
the kid's not going to spread
chronovirus to you kids
this has been established many times
over kids are very unlikely to contract
it and spread it
but even aside from that we're doing all
of this
to kids to protect ourselves because
we're afraid
this is this these aren't things we're
doing for them
it's things we're forcing them to do for
us
which is exactly backwards number four i
cancelled gender reveal parties on the
show earlier this week
you may remember the daily show with
trevor noah is behind the times they
came in and canceled them too
but frankly i thought my cancellation
was uh way better
than this watch but guys this has to
stop
right or at least if you insist on a
gender reveal you should do something
that helps the situation
the water's pink it's a girl and aside
from all the damage it can cause
celebrating a baby's genitalia is
starting to feel very outdated
like given everything we're learning
about gender gender reveal parties
should only happen when the child is old
enough to know their actual gender
and to pitch in some cash for the fire
damage
and honestly i don't even know why we
need gender reveal parties
you know what we do need though race
reveal parties
trevor noah's really has the charisma
and comedic chops of like a pillowcase
filled with wet sand and
i've never heard the guy tell a funny
joke have you i've never
i if anyone is aware of a funny trevor
noah
moment um from any point in his career
pre-daily show or during the dale show
let me know because i've never
i i've never seen it and i've looked and
the thing what the thing is
there was a time long ago when the daily
show might have done that exact same
segment with the same
lines and everything and it would have
been funny because the bit at the end
about choosing gender would have been
satirical it would have been a joke
10 years ago that bit would have been
satire
and today it is something that is
delivered in earnestness
and sincerity um by the way trevor
you say uh everything we've learned
about genders
what what is that exactly what what have
we learned what exactly have we learned
scientifically proving
that gender can be chosen rather than
rather than it being something you're
born with
i'd really like to know you said we've
learned okay we've learned a lot
everything we've learned
give me like one thing we've learned
that justifies what you just said
well he can't he can't they never can
all right we're gonna get to our daily
cancellation in just a second before we
do
um you know how much
do you think your personal information
is worth to cyber criminals research
uh researchers are compiled an overview
of the average price of stolen personal
data for sale in the dark web
while online banking logins cost an
average of 35 dollars
the range of documents and account
details needed to commit identity theft
cost 100 it'll cost 1285
so the bulk of stolen information comes
from large-scale
uh data breaches and what that means is
that you know this is you you have to
protect yourself when you're online
and that's why you need lifelock like i
have lifelock detects a wide range of
identity
threats like your social security number
being for sale in the dark web these are
the kinds of things that you're
you know you probably aren't going to
the dark web however you access that to
find out if your
information is on sale uh you need
lifelock for that you can do things like
check your bank account and check your
credit card balance and you should be
doing that but you need life lock for
everything else
if they detect your information has
potentially been compromised well
they're going to send you an alert and
if if you do have a problem they also
have identity theft restoration
specialists who are going to be there
and they're going to be able to help you
as well nobody can prevent all identity
theft or monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can find out if your
information is on is on sale in the dark
web
get your free dark web scan at
lifelock.com
scan pick the plan that's right for you
and save up to 25
off your first year with promo code
walsh that's a free scan at lifelock.com
scan and 25 off if you use promo code
walsh
let's get to our daily cancellation
today for our daily cancellation i'm
afraid that i must
cancel once again my wife for the
seventh time i believe
no husband wants to cancel his wife
seven times this is not what i wanted
for us for our marriage for our family
but i have been left with no choice um
and i present you now
all of the damning evidence that will be
needed to convict my wife
in cancellation court here it is right
there
this monstrosity this psychotic
assortment of stains and splotches
is allegedly a painting a piece of
artwork
that my wife went out and bought
presumably either from a crack addicted
hobo
or a 10 month old child or some
combination
of the two she brought it home years ago
and for years
i've tried to explain to her that this
looks like a k-mart brand jackson
pollock and
it brings shame to our family name but
she claims here's what she claims
that no this is not in fact a canvas
filled with random dribblings
but is actually a painting of a sailboat
two sailboats she claims i ask you do
you see
the sailboats where are the sailboats
show me the sailboats in that picture
you can't
and so we have waged a years-long cold
war over this thing it has changed
locations in the house multiple times
um at first it was in our living room
uh so that you know any guest who came
in could see it
and we could announce to all of our
guests that we are apparently
schizophrenic serial killers
and then she moved it to our room right
above our bed every night i fell asleep
with it watching me it invaded my dreams
feasted on my soul as i slept
and more recently it changes rooms
randomly i never know if it's going to
be there when i come around the corner
and she does this to torment me now you
might be saying to yourself
well matt you're the man of the house uh
why don't you
take the thing down and just throw it
away why don't you
take it down drive it out to the sea and
throw it in
let it drift away let some lonely deep
sea fisherman out in the atlantic
find it there floating and assume that
it's a bad omen which would cause him to
drown himself on purpose to
escape the coming wrath yes i've thought
about that believe me i would
i would do that but i haven't told you
the most sinister part of my wife's
scheme
she claims that the painting reminds her
of the eulogy the priest gave at her
grandmother's funeral
he spoke of the afterlife and made an
analogy to ships sailing over the
horizon the beautiful eulogy
and so she says this painting is
meaningful to her so she has emotionally
blackmailed me
but this is a one-way street i assure
you if i were to go out
and buy like a plastic singing trophy
fish
and hang it in the living room and then
say that it reminds me of my deceased
grandmother who was an eccentric
taxidermist my wife would very sweetly
say okay honey well let me help you find
something that we can put here to
remember your grandmother by just not
this
and she takes the fish down and escorts
it respectfully to the garbage can
so the thing is i like sailboats okay
sailboats are fun
yes let's have a painting of sailboats
you want a painting of sailboats in the
living room
great let's get a painting of sailboats
let's have a painting of a sailboat in
every room
let's go live in a sailboat i don't care
this is not an attack on sailboats my
problem is precisely that those are not
sail boats this is a rorschach test
and if you say that it looks like a
sailboat what that tells us
is that you don't have any idea what a
sailboat is
this is when it comes down to it really
modern abstract art isn't it
it is nonsense in other words it is an
assault on beauty
and objective truth it does violence to
the very foundations of human
civilization
it erodes the societal fabric i've tried
to explain all of this
it contradicts our deepest held
principles as people
it well what it really means is that my
wife
by buying and defending this painting
has revealed herself to be
a total lib and libs
are cancelled on this show in perpetuity
and so sadly today is my wife
very difficult moment for all of us
but a man reaches a point
where he must cancel his wife on his
podcast
i believe it was socrates who first said
that
we're gonna leave it there for today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical producer is austin stevens
edited by danny d'amico
and our audio is mixed by robin
fenderson the matt wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood
but on the andrew clavin show that's
where the fun just gets started so come
on over to the andrew clavin show and
laugh your way
through the apocalypse with me andrew
[Music]
clayton